bousculade à l'hôtel de ville de Paris
ce soir pour une cérémonie un peu
inattendue notre rockur national Johnny
hiday à peine sorti des sunlight du
festival de can a reçu des mains de
Jacques Chirac sa première distinction
officielle la plaque du bimillénaire de
la ville de Paris Henry Chapier n'a pas
manqué ce motement é
bourfant comme pour les concerts de rock
la voiture de Johnny arrive avec un
léger retard 18h45 à l'horloge de
l'Hôtel de Ville L Renault marine dans
le métier est déjà là qu' attend qui le
couve grande bousculade à l'entrée du
bureau du mer Johnny HID est un peu
intimidé Jacques Chirac s'amuse comme un
fan comme un
enfant demande si on va pas y aller
parce que tous vos autres il sont tout
le monde est arrivé presque il y a un
embouteillage démencoup de mal à à venir
vous pouvez me dire quelques
mots ça va est-ce que vous pensiez au
moment du golf d' haut qu'un jour vous
auriez cette médaille de la Ville de
Paris très franchement non non je ne
pensais pas du tout un jour même pouvoir
venir à la mairie de Paris et je suis
très honoré je suis j'ai pas très
habitué à ce genre de manifestation ça n
pas fait partie un peu de votre rêve
d'enfant comme prley a eu ce rêve aussi
d'être connu un jour
je suis très fier parce que en même
temps je suis très fier de représenter
la France à l'étranger quand je vais
quand je vais faire mon métier ailleurs
et c'est un honneur pour moi d'êtreç ici
et vous allez continuer de défendre la
chanson française comme vous l'avez fait
oui ben de plus en plus de plus en plus
on on essaie de d'écrire enfin
d'exporter des chansons françaises c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle j'ai j'ai
fait mon dernier album avec Michel
Berger c'est pour que nos chansons
soient françaises et que pour une fois
les Américains prennent nos chansons
plutôt que nous on prenne des chansons
américaines
merci Henri vous avez ce que vous allez
ce que vous voulez bien apr je vous
propose qu'on aille
jusur cette médaille Jacques shiracaura
gagné autant que Johnny HID vous ne
savez pas que le maire de Paris était un
tel connaisseur en matière de rock
qu'il défendait l'avenir de la chanson
française avec cette passion l'humour
n'a pas manqué à cette cérémonie ni même
l'émotion de tout curais vous dire merci
et puis là je je me parce que jeavais
pas un discours
merci